>> Narrator: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mary Jordan: I am so honored
to introduce our next author.
She's an elegant and
an exciting writer.
She's the kind of person that
other writers just adore.
Stacy Schiff.
And boy does she know
how to pick a good topic.
Unbelievable.
You know, even John Stuart
was interested in Cleopatra.
She is -- she somehow
brought to life Cleopatra
in a way that nobody else had.
And by the way, a lot of people
knew Cleopatra for a long time.
Of course she's won so many
prizes, it's fairly ridiculous.
When she was a child she won the
Pulitzer Prize, for writing "Vera",
about the wife of Vladimir Nabokov.
She was a runner up for the
Pulitzer even earlier in 1995.
And when she comes up here
and you see how young she is,
it's super annoying for the rest of
us writers [background laughter].
Ron Chernow, who knows how
to write a book himself,
said this about Stacy.
"Even if forced to, at gunpoint,
Stacy Schiff would be incapable
of writing a dull page
or a lame sentence.
And David McCullough, you know,
that guy that just always writes
best sellers just like Stacy?
His most recent, "The
Wright Brothers".
I love what he said about her.
"History in the hands of Stacy
Schiff is invariable full of life,
light, shadow, surprise,
clarity of insight.
And so it is again, and then some,
in her latest work, 'The Witches'.
Few writers combine as she
does superb scholarship
and an exceptional
gift for language,
with amazing reach
and agility of mind.
It is simply a superb book.
I'm going to turn it
over, setting the stage
in the hands of Stacy Schiff.
She brings you back to
17th Century Massachusetts.
It's an exceptionally cold winter.
And the mystery begins
when a minister's daughter
starts to scream.
Stacy.
[ Applause ]
>> Stacy Schiff: Thank you Mary.
If you're here at this hour,
you are either a die-hard
or a passionate lover
of history, or both.
Or you just want someone else to
walk your dog [background laughter].
We'd like to think
that history is eternal
and immobile like Mount Rushmore.
But it turns out to be
an oddly malleable thing.
It has moods and fashions,
and changes of heart.
It's studded with misconceptions
and outright fictions.
The Pilgrim's had never heard
anybody talk about Plymouth Rock.
And George Washington really
didn't have any particular grudge
against cherry trees.
Some of the lushest fictions grew
up around our commemorations
of the past.
Which reminds me of the
hands-down best-ever library joke.
A man walks into his
local library --
I can't tell this with
a straight face.
A man walks into his local library
and he asks, "Can you tell me why
so many major Civil War battles
were fought on national park land?"
[Background laughter] none of
which explains what we've done
with this one immutable truth.
During the summer of 1692,
upon much deliberation,
the Massachusetts Bay Colony
executed 19 people for witchcraft.
Those innocent men and women --
they were 14 women and 5 men --
were convicted in the Salem,
Massachusetts courtroom.
They hanged several
miles away on a spot --
and this will tell you something
about how the epidemic was viewed
in its immediate aftermath --
in a spot that we can
barely locate today.
Sometimes it seems as if the
trauma of an event can be measured
by how long it takes
us to commemorate it.
And by how thoroughly we
mangle it in the process.
Because if you go back to
Salem today to get a taste
of this startling chapter
in our history,
you discover that the
town has embraced its past
with what you might call an uncommon
fervor [background laughter].
In 1692, nearly 180 people
were accused of witchcraft,
but none of them was a
pirate [background laughter].
One of them was a Harvard
educated minister,
and another was the richest merchant
in Salem, but that's something else.
For several hundred years, Salem
did everything it could, in fact,
to bury this chapter of its history.
As late as 1952 when Arthur Miller
visited to research "The Crucible",
the subject of witchcraft was taboo.
"You couldn't get anyone
to say anything about it."
Complained Miller.
The stigma lifted only with the
Salem filming of the ABC sitcom,
"Bewitched" [background laughter].
I see some of you remember
that show.
The conceit of that show was
that a modern housewife
had supernatural powers.
And that with a twitch of her nose,
she would open the garage door;
make the vacuum cleaner work.
This was annoying to
her very mortal husband.
For various reasons it made
sense in 1970 to shoot a number
of sitcom episodes in Salem.
And that allowed the town to
embrace its inglorious past.
And here is how it did so.
In 1992 it unveiled
this gleaming memorial
to Elizabeth Montgomery
[background laughter],
the television show's star.
She had effectively
laundered the history.
And so over the next years, Salem
vigorously re-branded itself.
This is the town paper.
This is the football team
[background laughter].
And this is the police cruiser.
Generally, it became -- it
turned itself into "Witch City".
Every possible slogan, you get to
see every one of these when you walk
around Salem, but this
is my favorite;
this is a t-shirt [background
laughter].
After "Bewitched", a community
of Wiccans established themselves
in Salem, and it's today a very
good place to buy crystals,
or a broomstick, or a magic wand.
It's also a very good place,
by the way, to get a tattoo.
A witch museum opened
in a former church.
The restored home of one of the --
of the 1692 judges recast
itself as the "Witch House".
And of course Halloween now
belongs completely to Salem,
where October 31st is a
month-long celebration.
This is particularly
ironic, as the Puritans --
and in 1692, most of New England was
Puritan -- had a horror of holidays.
They renounced Christmas and
Saints Days, and they wound
up with a calendar that
has been described as,
"The dullest in Western
civilization" [background laughter].
But in other words, you
could leave Salem today
without a hint of its
actual history.
But you'd better book now if you
want a room for next Halloween.
What precisely did happen in 1692?
Toward the end of January, after
an especially harsh winter,
two little girls began to
bark and yelp and shutter.
They fell dumb.
They seemed to fly across rooms.
They lived in what was then
known as Salem Village.
A hamlet five miles down
the road from Salem Town.
And a community today known,
to its immense relief,
as Danvers, Massachusetts.
The girl's father and uncle was
the village minister, Samuel Paris.
For some time, he resisted what
seemed the obvious diagnosis.
Four years earlier, a family
of Boston children had
suffered identical symptoms.
They accused a local woman of
having cast a spell on them.
She hanged in November, 1688.
That case was very well-known.
Probably as much to the village
children as to their parents.
After weeks of prayer with no
change in the girl's condition,
and no other viable explanation
for it, it seemed clear
that witchcraft was at work.
The girls soon named three
names, and three different --
said that three different
women had enchanted them.
One of them quickly confessed
that she was, in fact, a witch.
She did so in kaleidoscopic detail
with a story about yellow birds,
and red cats, and black hogs.
She said she'd been recruited
by the Devil himself.
And that she'd flown in the
wink of an eye to Boston.
She had had several accomplices.
Three separate reporters
took down her testimony,
which created a sensation.
Immediately, grown men began
to hear unearthly sounds.
They met with large, winged
beasts in the moonlight.
Already the girl's symptoms
had spread to a cohort
of teenagers; many of them servants.
They would play the
starring roles in 1692.
Identifying the witches.
Displaying their bruises
and their bites,
and their bloodied
limbs to the courtroom.
Ultimately predicting whom
the witches would attack next.
Fingers pointed soon
in all directions.
The epidemic spread
to 24 communities.
We call them the "Salem
witch trials", but Andover,
Massachusetts was the village
most severely affected.
One in ten of its residents
would be denounced.
So many stood accused, that
witnesses confused their suspects.
The youngest was five,
and the eldest nearly 80.
Daughters accused mothers.
Brothers their sisters.
Parishioners their ministers.
With astonishing frequency,
husbands tended to assure the court
that they had long suspected
that their wives were
witches [background laughter].
Let me talk for just a few minutes
about witchcraft and how it worked.
What exactly was a witch?
To the early Americans, she
existed -- or he existed --
as plainly as did heat or light.
As one authority had
it, it was as obvious
that a spirit could convey
men and women through the air,
as it was that the wind
could flatten a house.
The early American witch -- I should
add -- did not look like this.
Although there is something of "The
Wizard of Oz" about the Salem story.
And nor did the 17th
Century witch look like this.
This, by the way, is the
original Wicked Witch of the West,
from the 1900 edition
of "The Wizard of Oz".
I particularly like the flying
pigtail, and those unexpected spats.
This is an early Halloween witch.
Or it should be.
There she is.
The first Halloween was celebrated
without witches, and when finally,
the witches appear on the
scene, the tend to be colorful.
They only become --
they only dress in black
after the 1939 "Wizard of Oz" movie.
The witches of 17th Century New
Englander knew her as someone
who performed unnatural
feats by virtue
of her contract with the Devil.
And from that pact, she drew
the power to transform herself
into cats, wolves, rabbits.
A witch could be a man or a woman,
though she was more often female.
And she had a menagerie of imps,
or familiars who did her bidding.
Those could be turtles or weasels.
Cats, dogs, and toads
were prevalent.
This 17th Century woman was feeding
her blood to her diabolical toads.
This is a woman with her
great black cat familiar.
She illustrates a 1621 English case,
and in fact, this woman is acquitted
of all witchcraft charges.
These are more diabolical familiars.
And you'll see that they range from
the standard issue barnyard pig
to fantastical, gargoyle-like
creatures.
A surprising number
of Massachusetts men
in 1692 would report
assaults in their bed by cats.
By over-sized cats.
Killer cats.
Glow-in-the-dark cats, or
neighbors disguised as cats.
Black cats were the
favorites, though they turn
up throughout the Salem testimony.
Black dogs recur in
the Salem records too,
though historically English witches
tended to prefer feline form.
This, by the way, is
not a witches familiar,
this is our family cat
[background laughter], Moose,
looking I hope just a little bit
demonic [background laughter].
A witch signed her pact with the
Devil in blood, and she enchanted
with ointments and effigies.
She could be a muttering,
contentious malcontent.
Or she or he could be explicably
strong and unaccountably smart.
Both kinds of witches would turn up
in 1692, as would wealthy merchants
who were witches, sea captains
who were witches, ministers
and homeless five-year-old
girls who were witches.
While her power was supernatural,
her crime was religious.
And her ultimate target was
the soul rather than the body.
And her connection to
the convulsing children?
Every Englishman had long known
what enchantment looked like.
According to the legal guide
on many Massachusetts' desks,
and which was about to land on
the Salem minister's desk --
this is the volume -- it manifested
as trances, paralyzed limbs,
frothing, gnashing,
and violent shaking.
In other words, the
symptoms of the Salem girls
to a T. Among the abundant proofs
of her existence was the
biblical injunction against her.
"Thou shalt not suffer a witch
to live" commands scripture --
I'm sorry to have to share with
you the basic English translation
of Exodus 22:18.
Which is, "Any woman
using unnatural powers
or secret arts is to
be put to death."
That pretty much covers every
woman I know [background laughter].
When Massachusetts
establishes its legal code,
the first capital crime
was idolatry,
and the second was witchcraft.
Just so you know, blasphemy
comes next,
and murder only comes
after blasphemy.
In the years since those
laws had been codified,
New England had indicted
about 100 witches.
Massachusetts, however,
had hanged only six.
So beside the mystery of the
Salem symptoms is really a
greater mystery.
Why in 1692, the hasty
and merciless prosecution?
The charges were familiar
from earlier cases.
Casting spells on livestock
was a common one.
Salem witches enchanted
fireplaces, and muskets and wagons.
They sent dishes sailing.
They bit and they clawed and they
bludgeoned anyone who would refuse
to sign the "Devil's Book".
This wood cut is from
an early English case.
These accused women
did not fare well.
Why though are they riding a pig?
Oh, they're not riding a pig.
Oh no, they seem to have gone away.
Oh well. They should've been
riding a pig below that.
Some witchcraft is
clearly at work here.
They've been accused of pig
bewitching is the short of it.
New England witches do
a great deal of flying
down chimneys, and over apple trees.
And ultimately to a
diabolical Sabbath.
But traditionally, the
English witch did not fly.
Continental witches however did,
which will provide a significant
clue as to what happened in 1692.
Those who confess to witchcraft
will have flown, I should add,
by their own confession,
on the Devil's shoulders,
or on poles; on branches or sticks.
No New England witch
would ever fly on a broom.
Here are possibly -- there
they are -- some French fliers.
This is 15th Century, but leave
it to a French woman to be able
to fly gracefully [background
laughter].
The accepted logic on the
phenomenon went like this.
Witches existed in
all times and places.
How is it possible that imagination
could deliver the same conceit
across cultures and eras?
In other words, witchcraft was
so preposterous, you
couldn't make it up.
To the impossibility
of a shared delusion,
was that of the most compelling
reason to believe in witchcraft.
Not to subscribe to it was heresy.
In 1692 then, a witch
could be someone
who was a foot stamper
or a troublemaker.
But it could also be someone
who simply denied the
existence of witchcraft.
Faith aside served a purpose.
It made sense of the
unfortunate and the eerie.
The sick child and the
disappearing kitchen scissors.
What else?
Shrugged one husband in court,
might've caused those black
and blue marks on his wife's arms.
One more breathtaking
thing about the trials.
They came to an end
because the scope
of the crisis taxed the imagination.
Could there really be
that many witches flitting
around Massachusetts?
And because of what appeared
to be an over-zealous court.
Carefully, quietly, and anonymously,
sane men began to speak up.
Few of them however, questioned
the existence of witchcraft.
At issue was simply the
difficulty in identifying it.
Many would believe that
innocence had died in 1692,
but most also believed that
guilty witches had escaped.
To my mind, writers could
be immensely unhelpful
about what nudges them
toward a particular subject.
I can't say precisely where
my interest in Salem began,
but I can report that you don't
head off into the long haul
of writing a book without
some kind of obsession.
The kind that wakes
you up in the night.
That makes you read the daily
newspaper through the eyes
of someone who lives centuries,
or hundreds of centuries earlier.
And so I began thinking
about Salem; it began to feel
to me eerily topical and familiar.
Oral culture, like internet
culture, feeds on rumor.
Both very effectively
so mass hysteria.
We too know something
about conspiracies
and their political utility.
About how fear can
corrode our thinking.
About how raging against the
powers of darkness can convince us
that we stand in the light.
Here was an instructive tale about
a very different war on terror.
About the politics of fear.
Both of them conducted
by enlightened men.
Because of the center of the events
in 1692 were increased, Mather,
the most illustrious of
Massachusetts' ministers,
and his brilliant 29-year-old
son, Cotton.
Cotton Mather had no trouble
with hysteria whipping its
way through Massachusetts.
He was convinced that the colony was
under assault from
a subversive crew.
More to the point, he
relished that attack,
which proved the colony's
special status.
The epidemic seemed
like a badge of honor.
Further proof that New
Englanders were the chosen people.
American exceptionalism
really begins here.
The civic authorities
regularly appealed
to the Mathers for guidance.
They owned the most
extensive collection
of printed matter in Massachusetts.
They had devoured libraries
on the subject of witchcraft.
It was to Cotton Mather
that we owe our knowledge
of the earlier Boston epidemic.
He had published a best-selling
volume on the subject.
He wrote more about
Salem than anyone else.
A decade afterward,
he was still puzzling
over what could've caused
the witchcraft epidemic.
He concluded, for the
record, that it was the fault
of the Native Americans
[background laughter].
One additional thing that may have
contributed to my Salem obsession.
It's not lost on me that after
writing about Ben Franklin's years
in France -- eight years for
which there's two-and-a-half times
as much documentation as the
rest of Franklin's life combined.
I wrote, "A Life of Cleopatra", for
which there is of course no shred
of documentation whatsoever.
So here with "Salem",
blessedly was an archive.
It included diaries and
sermons, and church record books.
And best of all, nearly 1,000
transcripts of depositions,
arrest warrants; petitions.
This is a page.
This is the best of 17th Century
penmanship, from the sermon book
of Samuel Paris -- the
Salem Village minister.
This is the accounting of
one of the many jail keeps
who incarcerated the witch suspects.
A 17th Century prisoner,
had the obligation
for paying for his own charges.
So the jailers tended to be very
meticulous in their records.
The trials then struck me as
terrifically, urgently relevant.
Especially when you
factored in the anxiety,
and the very familiar
conspiracy theories.
I think we're always
obsessed with our origins.
And thanks in large part to
Hawthorne and to Arthur Miller,
the trials have inserted
themselves into our DNA.
In talking about "The Witches" this
past year, it sometimes seems to me
that half of America
descends from some settler
of 17th Century New England, and the
other half starred in "The Crucible"
in high school [background
laughter].
Let me end with the
witchcraft confession
of a 72-year-old farmwoman.
Because for me, she was the start of
the story, and finally of the book.
We don't know who initially
accused Anne Foster.
But we do know that she
submitted to three very intense,
back-to-back interrogations.
Initially she denied any
involvement with witchcraft.
But soon she began to
unspool an astonishing tale.
I should say that six
alleged witches had hanged
by this time; it's now mid-summer.
The epidemic really
takes off at a gallop.
It begins in January or
February, and from start
to finish it lasts only 10 months.
The Devil, Foster admitted,
had appeared to her as a bird.
And at his direction she had
bewitched several children
and a hog.
This is the record, by the way,
and through repeated examination.
This is not the best of
17th Century handwriting.
A neighbor who was a witch, had led
her to a diabolical Sabbath in May,
arranging their trip
through the air.
Foster provided precise
details of that gathering,
to which the witches have flown
from all over New England.
We can reconstruct the meeting
from over 50 sworn testimonies.
But alas, we have no image.
This is the closest we can come.
This is a 17th Century engraving
of a German witch's Sabbath.
It's a far more decadent production,
but certain themes are familiar
as these men and women also fly
by various means to a clearing.
You remember that I said
that there had been no flying
in Massachusetts before 1692,
well suddenly everyone is aloft.
In her second interrogation,
Foster revealed that she'd flown
to the meeting on a pole.
One that she shared
with her neighbor.
As they sailed through the
air, the woman had crashed.
They took off a second
time though, thought --
though Foster had hurt
her leg in the fall,
you can see that there was -- she
was not the first woman to plunge
to the ground at such a moment.
We know about the crash not
only from her official account,
but because a local minister
had heard her confess,
and he had questioned her
privately afterward in prison.
He was fascinated by the
mechanics of witchcraft.
Did she ride to the
meeting on a stick?
What had she done about food?
She told him that she had carried
bread and cheese in her pocket.
She described the sandy
ground on which she sat.
She provided details of the timing
of the flight in both directions.
As for the accident, she claimed
that her leg still hurt her.
She was entirely forthcoming,
balking only when asked
if it was true that she'd
recruited her daughter
into the Satanic conspiracy.
It hardly mattered
that she denied that,
because her daughter
immediately confessed;
incriminating her mother
as she did so.
Foster's 18-year-old granddaughter
was arrested after that.
She assured the authorities
that both her mother
and her grandmother
practiced witchcraft.
But let me go back to
Anne Foster's account.
To enter into the world
of the early American.
To grasp what could power a
witchcraft epidemic, you have to buy
into what we today
consider to be a delusion.
This was a novel merit
of challenge for me.
Essentially I was writing
a book of non-fiction,
which had at its center
an illusory event.
So in short, the challenge was
to make a crazy thing
seem perfectly rational.
And then afterward, to
show why it had been crazy.
Foster's crash seemed
to me to point the way.
Here was a woman who not only
believed she had attended a
diabolical Sabbath, or had reason
to lead others to believe she had,
but who had envisioned
difficulties getting there
and felt she could still
feel its aftereffects.
Moreover, that Sabbath stood
at the center of the story.
The authorities felt
that it amounted
to a full-blown conspiracy
against the state.
They felt the witches were
plotting to overthrow the church
and Massachusetts'
newly seated government.
So this was the original
plot against America.
Foster reported there
were 25 conspirators;
her granddaughter said 70.
And the estimates would
soon rise to 500.
Its gravity, in part, explained
the ruthless prosecution.
The witchcraft became a
political crisis for a colony
that felt vulnerable for
any number of reasons,
having nothing to do
with witchcraft.
All of which convinced me that the
book opened with Foster's flight.
It sends us into the heart of the
matter, and it signals to the reader
that odd and implausible
things were afoot.
I had to begin then with
how Anne Foster had traveled
from her Andover farm
to a diabolical meeting
in Salem 12 miles away.
Here was the initial stab at
the first line of the witches --
yes, I write on yellow legal pad.
So it's -- I know,
it's embarrassing.
This ultimately became the
first line of Chapter Two,
because I much later
wrote an introduction
which my canny publisher
retitled Chapter One, "Because",
he explained, "No one
reads introductions."
Should you care to know how
long it takes to write a book,
it seems that I made these attempts
at an opening line on April 8, 2013,
and I did not see my children
for the next two years.
By later that day, the
line had evolved to this.
I had in hand Anne Foster's sworn
testimony, along with the account
of that minister who
interviewed her in prison.
But I also had to check
a number of details.
For example, if in fact, you
flew just above the treetops,
southeast from Andover to Salem,
what exactly did you
see below you in 1692?
Could you see as far as the ocean?
How thick were the trees?
Through this I plagued the
Danvers's town archivist
who was kind enough
to take me seriously.
And of course I needed
to verify the inky night.
Thereupon followed an
extensive correspondence
of my favorite research librarian.
A man of superhuman tenacity, of
which this will give you some idea.
This is one of several multi-page
emails in which he confirmed
that in fact, the night of
May 15, 1692 was not inky.
A bright, gibbous moon shown
over Massachusetts that evening.
So yes, you're hearing correctly.
I spent hours checking
the factual circumstances
under which a fictive event took
place, which is surely a definition
of lunacy [background laughter].
But let me point out
something else too.
In trying to recreate Foster's
flight, which she had described
in exquisite detail,
I too had landed
in the proverbial dark
wilderness of error.
You may have noticed it already,
but I didn't see it for months.
Indeed, Foster had claimed
that she'd flown at high speed
over the trees to the
Salem gathering.
And indeed, she had
done so on May 15
when there was a bright
moon in the sky.
But nowhere had she said
that she'd flown at night.
This is the kind of thing that
makes you sit bolt upright
in bed at 3:00 in the morning.
As I did many, many months
after I'd written those lines.
I went back and I reread every
account of the Satanic celebration.
Not one of the 50 people
included a word about the dark,
or about navigating the dark.
In fact, no one seemed to have
had any trouble seeing at all.
Some of the celebrants talked
about the color of the wine.
Several confessed that they had
signed the Devil's book in red.
Details they would've had
trouble ascertaining by moonlight.
In part I was a victim
of my research.
I had wanted to tie Foster's flight
to that of another woman who rode
through the darkness in
1704, if on horseback.
I had wanted to stress how much the
dark, the velvety, sound-amplifying,
disorienting, terrifying blackness
was a player in the story.
And after all, everybody
knows witches fly at night.
Of course when I went back
to look, there it was.
Foster's granddaughter very
plainly tells the justices
that the meeting had
taken place at noon.
And so ultimately in the
final draft, a plush carpet
of meadows unfurls below Anne
Foster as she flies to Salem --
or at least swears that she did --
over red maples, and
over meandering streams.
There's a bright moon in the
sky which is no longer dark.
There were, of course, no
flights through the air in 1692,
or goblins in the parlor,
or supernatural conspiracies
in a meadow.
How then did these
things seem to happen?
When you pry the whole
chapter apart,
you see that it makes uncanny
and wholly modern sense.
I tell you about Anne Foster,
because I hope that you may take
from the book what I
took from my misreading.
A reminder of how swiftly
we jump to conclusions.
How easily ignorance and
information can lead us astray.
Fear warps our thinking.
Preconceived notions trip us up.
We like to lead but explanations.
Above all, the Salem history
reminds us of the importance
of keeping our heads, even when
that leaves a question unresolved.
Even when it leaves us off balance.
That's an uncomfortable state.
But as a later Bostonian
noted, bewilderment is crucial.
We would be lost, in
fact, without it.
"It seems probable", wrote Henry
James 200 years after the trials,
"If we were never bewildered,
there would never be a
story to tell about us."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
We have time for questions,
and there are two microphones
in the aisles for whoever
gets there first.
>> Question: I'm wondering about why
people would confess to something
that they didn't really do.
But you know, there was this
situation in Central Park
with the Central Park Five.
These were teenage boys
and they confessed.
The police worked them
over, but they confessed
to crimes that they didn't commit.
And I'm wondering what the process
is, whereby somebody's going
to do something like that?
>> Stacy Schiff: Turns
out to be remarkably easy
to extract a false confession.
But it -- in the case of Salem, it's
exacerbated by a few other issues.
First of all, with some of the
young men that are accused,
they are actually tortured.
And we have evidence of the
fact that they had been hung
up in a rather grotesque fashion, to
have the truth extracted from them.
But many of the people who
are brought in are women.
Many of them have never been --
have never stood before
an authority before.
The men who were interrogating them
are the best-dressed, wealthiest,
best-spoken men in the colony.
They're terrified.
They often are men who are able
to reason very logically
and very nimbly.
So that, for example, a woman
who comes into the court
and says, "I'm not a witch.
I've never practiced witchcraft.
I don't even know what a witch is."
Is immediately asked, "How then can
you be certain you're not a witch,
if you don't know what a witch is?"
So you see, the manner
of questioning was [laughs] rather
circular, and rather imprisoning.
It's exacerbated by the fact
that confession comes rather
naturally to a Puritan.
And this sense of inadequacy, and
the fear that you might actually,
on some level be complicity.
It's very close to the surface.
So that you hear in the -- in some
of the testimony, people saying,
"I wasn't able to confess,
but I don't know if I couldn't
because I was innocent, or if
the Devil was stopping my words."
So there's a certain confusion.
Everyone feels he has a
spot on his conscious;
a blemish on his conscious
of some kind.
And there's -- because there's no
such thing as a guilty conscious
in the 17th Century, that must
feel diabolical in some way.
By mid-summer, the
confessions begin to run rampant
for an additional reason.
Which is that it had
become clear to people
that if you confessed,
you did not hang.
So only the people who resist the
authorities who go to the gallows.
And so confession is used as an
additional means of protection.
And of course inside every
confession is a gleaming bit
of shrapnel known as an accusation.
Because if you confess,
you generally hand
over the name of your coconspirator.
And that is one of the reasons
that the epidemic spreads
with the fury that it does.
Yes?
>> Question: Hi.
So a large part, obviously,
is the whole Salem witch
epidemic is gender politics
in 17th Century Massachusetts.
But also interested in
hearing your thoughts
on Arthur Miller's later take
on the Salem witch trials,
and particularly how, at least
in my thoughts, it kind of adds
to those gender politics in a
way that it makes the women;
the young girls who, at
the center of the story,
to be the accusers; the evil ones.
Rather than the individuals
who may simply be trying
to assert whatever power
and agency they might have.
>> Stacy Schiff: I guess the
short answer to your question,
Miller diverges from the actual
records in any -- in a zillion ways.
Whatever you think of
the "The Crucible",
it's a play; it's not history.
But the most interesting thing I
think he does with the girls is
to sexualize them and to sexualize
the relationship with John Proctor.
Obviously, to do that he has to
raise the age of Abigail, of course.
But he gives -- he makes
this into sexual politics.
The missing piece -- among the
many missing pieces about Salem is,
did any of these girls actually
suffer some kind of sexual abuse?
They're -- the colony feels
vulnerable at this time.
The girls feel tremendously
vulnerable.
They're living in a world where
Indian attack is imminent.
And many of them have
survived Indian attacks,
where they have often been -- where
girls have often been assaulted
by their -- the men in the
homes in which they live.
Most of these girls
didn't live at home.
They're servants in
other people's homes.
Which means that they are
prey to their masters.
The boys in the house; the
other servants in the house.
There's a lot of sexual
imagery in the accusations,
but we can't pin any of it
to these particular girls.
There are any number of aggressions;
rapes, unwanted advances
in the court records; but
not in the Salem records.
It's very hard to connect the two.
And I guess that's
where I would say is
that Miller took the greatest
liberty, was in using some
of those vulnerabilities and
attaching them to the story.
Where we know a lot about -- seeing
hints that these girls have dropped,
but we have nothing on the record.
Yes, sir?
>> Question: A personal question.
In 1953, a fellow
from my neighborhood
named Arthur Miller went,
and he was very much
influenced by the McCarthy era.
And he went to Salem because
he was looking at an image.
Did you have something like that,
a political thing in your mind
that motivated you
to go and do that?
>> Stacy Schiff: Arthur
Miller's wonderfully clear
about what his motives
were, and you know,
obviously the McCarthy beat was
a perfect analogy in many ways.
>> Question: Yes.
>> Stacy Schiff: As I said, I'm not
particularly adept at being able
to say why I wrote something.
I'll give you an example of that.
Only after I finished this book,
for reasons which I thought I had
just explained, did a friend say
to me, "Did you notice that the
entire time you were working
on this book, you were living
with an adolescent girl?"
No, that was totally
lost on me in fact.
And moreover, a girl who
was between the age --
was of the age of the accusers
of the bewitched girls.
I would say that I was
reading this material
about this subversive assault.
About these swarthy
terrorists in the yard.
Because a lot of this is about
the Indians lurking outside.
And the nefarious Catholics were
about to disembark in Boston harbor,
and you know, take over
the Puritan establishment.
I was reading all of
that in the wake of Iraq.
And yes, I think I probably
saw an echo of this kind
of alien invader idea;
these invisible enemies,
you know, lurking among us.
Our -- all of our -- it's
really all about, in many ways,
terrorism and immigration.
And those are two issues
which we seem
to be grappling with still today.
So yes, I think that may have been
some of it, but I didn't really see
that in any conscious
way at the time.
>> Question: Thank you.
>> Stacy Schiff: You're welcome.
Yes, sir?
>> Question: So I did not
act in "The Crucible", but --
and actually a direct descendant
of Suzannah North Martin,
who was one of the
witches who was killed --
>> Stacy Schiff: My favorite.
>> Question: And so
one, I'll be interested
in any little stories
you might have about her.
But the lore from the family is
that she was targeted as a widow
who was sort of in a family,
you know, property dispute.
And so I was wondering how much you
think there was sort of intentional,
kind of bickering and
targeting going on.
And whether, as in a general matter,
whether sort of new arrivals;
sort of the immigrants to the area,
or whatever, was there any kind
of rational way that there was
certain people being fingered?
>> Stacy Schiff: Suzannah
Martin's one of my favorites,
because she's one of
the few of the accused
who actually uses sarcasm
in the court.
And she is very disrespectful
with the justices.
She's been strident and
outspoken in the past.
And she's been accused of
witchcraft in the past.
And that's true of a number
of the suspects in 1692.
It's very hard to determine if
they had been accused in the past
because they were strident,
or if they're strident
because they've been
accused in the past.
But all of those leftover
accusations come back --
all of those former
accusations come back
to be reactivated by
the fury in 1692.
No one really seems to
be prosecuted for reasons
of claiming his or her property.
But many people are -- and many
people seem to be prosecuted for --
accused for different reasons.
In one case there is a decades-old,
longstanding, unresolved,
overly litigated familial
grudge over a property line.
And that claims a few lives.
In Suzannah Martin
and a few other cases,
there had been previous court cases,
which people still had
bad feelings about.
In many cases, men are accused
because they had formerly
been officials;
constables; justices of the peace.
And they had told people
what they didn't want
to hear, and so they are accused.
And in fact in one case, an
Andover constable is accused
because he refuses to round
up any more witch suspects.
And so after his saying,
I -- you know, "I'm done",
he's immediately accused
of witchcraft.
Yes?
>> Question: You eluded to it
earlier when you showed some notes
on a legal pad and different
drafts that you had for,
you know, for "The Witches".
>> Stacy Schiff: Yeah, that
embarrassing thing I showed you?
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Question: Yeah, well I
didn't find it too embarrassing,
but my question is, can you take us
through when you have an
idea to finished product?
Do you have motivation
and then you kind
of outline what the book will be?
Or do you just start writing?
And do you allow it to
pivot from point-to-point?
>> Stacy Schiff: In short -- because
I could do this for several hours --
it usually takes me
four to five years,
of which I spend the first
three years in the archive.
So I really have no idea
where the book begins.
I have no idea what I'm
looking for necessarily.
And I'm just kind of following
my way through the archive,
and just reading as much as I can.
For example, I didn't know when I
started this book that I was going
to be reading mountains
of Puritan sermons.
Had I known that, I probably
wouldn't have attempted this book.
Not really good for the
soul [background laughter].
And I don't start till I really
-- till the material starts to,
in some way, marinate or ferment,
or whatever verb you
want to use, in my mind.
I knew Anne Foster was going
to be the way into the story,
but you're always surprised
by what you find.
And the whole idea is, in a funny
way, to have a very open mind
when you first begin a project.
Because you don't really
-- if you follow your --
if you follow a thesis
through the woods,
you're going to end up
proving your thesis.
And especially in this case, where
I felt it really incumbent on me
to leave the answers to the
end of the book so that it read
as a thriller, with the real
explanations on the end.
That was important, as was the
idea of conveying what it felt
like to live and breathe
the New England air in 1692.
What did these people dream about?
What did they fear?
What were their preoccupations?
What were their obsessions?
What were they yearning for?
And that was something I hadn't
found in a previous book.
And I'm being told we
have one minute left.
So if you have a quick question --
>> Question: Yes, so I was
just wondering about the extent
of the research that you do.
Like, did you find
yourself in a courtroom?
Did you find yourself
talking to like,
a geologist about like
what the rocks looked like?
Or you know, kind of just, what kind
of wood did they use
to build their cabins.
Like did you actually sit
in a courtroom and see how
that would be displayed even
though it was still rough
like [inaudible] --
>> Stacy Schiff: I try to get as
close as I can to ground-level.
This is harder when you're
writing about Cleopatra, you know,
in a world that -- I mean
Cleopatra's Egypt is gone.
Only the coast -- not even the
coast is in the right place.
The moon is in the right
place; that's about it.
So this was a little bit easier,
but it's very hard to recreate.
At one point, I said to
an archivist, you know,
"What did the houses smell like?"
And he said, you know, "Go
to Plymouth Plantation."
Brilliant!
I hadn't thought of it.
And I went to Plymouth Plantation
and I said to the women --
"What are the" -- the
women reenactors --
"What are the worst
months of the year?"
And every single one of them
said, "January and February".
Which, of course, is precisely
when the witchcraft broke out.
Just saying.
Anyway, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Narrator: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov